what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time well while
she's trying to get rich
russell is just trying to get her lunch
money right i'm here with the beautiful
intelligent and sometimes funny paulina
marinova
what if i'm trying to get rich yeah
while wall street's trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get lunch
but what if i'm trying to get rich
are you yeah well you first got to get
your lunch money then you get wait this
is the microphone sorry
i was like i was like looking at the
camera because that my friends are over
there but then i have to talk into this
sorry guys
all right finished lunch money is
sponsored by block five block fi has
three products you can buy and sell
cryptocurrencies you can deposit crypto
and take out a us dollar loan against it
she's drinking starbucks that's cool so
am i
uh and on top of that you can use an
interest bearing account the interest
bearing accounts pay up to 8.6
apy it is in my opinion a no-brainer
there's risk go do your research
but i use it i love it the first monday
of every month should be called block
five day because we get interest
payments
passive income what's up get money get
paid
go check out block five block lunch
money
what's up are you good i'm looking at my
hair real quick
okay the housing market i didn't sleep a
lot last night i only got six hours of
sleep because i was up doing all kinds
of crazy stuff i was ordering books off
amazon i don't know what i was doing
last night
but your boy is ready i was getting
hyped last night uh he was reading these
books he was reading these articles i
was watching some trash now you want to
know what else i was hype
what 100 000 subscribers that's what we
hit yesterday on youtube
a hundred thousand thank you guys shout
out to every single one of you guys
that's awesome 100 000 subscribers that
was my goal for all of 2020 we hit it
all
in august and for you guys in the
comments that have been watching this
since day one i appreciate you
i'm gonna do something special for you
guys but after we hit 200 000
what you're gonna do don't worry about
it i got i got ideas i got ideas all
right let's go let's get into this stuff
let's keep stop the
people from waiting i got a birthday
coming up he ain't saying that to me
yeah okay 21st i think fourth okay
the housing market is still going strong
and continues to be a bright spot in the
u.s
economy that has been ravaged by the
virus so the government said tuesday
that building permits and housing
starts both starts both surged
in july and easily topped economist
forecasts
home depot rep home depot reported sales
and earnings for the second quarter
tuesday that rose more than 20
from a year ago you want to know my
favorite thing about you reading some of
this stuff
is when you come across something like
how no when you come across something
like housing starts
and you don't know if that's a typo or
if that's an economic metric
oh it's a magic it's a metric god why
are all the metrics grammatically
incorrect so long story short is uh
they flooded the market they being the
federal reserve and the us government to
flood the market with cheap capital
there's a financial incentive for you to
go borrow money
and to buy homes to refinance to do to
refurbish
remodeling well the other part of the
remodeling that's really interesting is
there's a lot of people who are just
sitting at home
no i know multiple people who are doing
who are building who are doing home
thing projects like my friend in georgia
built a deck
of course well because they're just
sitting at home and like what can i do
oh what we should get a deck and then
they go and they're like well
screw it i'll just take the time to
build it now while i'm sitting here at
home it's kind of like last night when i
just was sitting there and i was like oh
i guess i should go put together that
piece of furniture that you've been in
let's not talk about that
which i did do uh but the whole idea is
that's why they're building stuff right
and so of course where do you go you go
to home depot that's where you go get
stuff
uh shout out ken langone um and
i think that the that's the ceo of home
depot or
no founder of home one of the founders
uh the idea that
um there's a financial incentive to go
and restructure your mortgage to go buy
uh a new home leads to people doing that
stuff right so literally think of it as
like the government is almost paying
people
by manipulating the interest rates uh to
go do this stuff and so of course
uh you're gonna get the uh the impact
that uh they're trying to get
should we should we like go buy a home
different cities
sure yeah we'll see all right what's up
what's up with the next one
what's up what's up so i'm very confused
here because
remember why why is tick tock like the
hot girl at the party
oracle is now in talks to acquire tick
tocks u.s operations
challenging microsoft i don't think that
tick tock is the hot girl at the party i
think that it's the hot guy at the party
who has commitment issues
wait no no no oh yeah yeah yeah because
every everyone's courting like
all of the people are trying to get but
tick tock has commitment and also
his parents are like okay
no no no no no no no
so tick-tock basically uh is now under
this uh executive order from the
president united states
who says hey you guys have to divest of
uh tick-tock
um and it's gonna be illegal for anybody
in the united states any corporation to
do business uh transactions
um and so i think that there's this
scramble and you've got microsoft you've
got twitter you've got now oracle a
bunch of companies have
uh kind of kicked the tires on this well
what is oracle going to do with
tick tock let's be real if they're smart
they're just going to buy it and let it
run and not touch it i see
right and so the idea here is that it
sounds like oracle's trying to team up
with some u.s venture capitalists which
would make a lot of sense
most of the venture capitalists that are
probably interested in this have
experience
investing some of them running and some
of them are invested
in tick tock yeah general atlantic
sequoia right it's like that would be
super interesting if all of a sudden
venture capitalists went more of the
private equity route and actually bought
a majority ownership
uh in concert with uh oracle so at the
end of the day
i actually think that uh i'm calling it
now
instagram is gonna kill tik tok oh you
don't think
facebook is gonna try to buy tick tock
no why would they have instagram
i don't know how long it's gonna take
but in the next 18 months i wouldn't be
surprised if we start seeing articles
like
real reals is more popular i already
hate reels i'm seeing
why women who are in their like 50s
doing all the dances and like i don't
want to see this in my instagram feed
i'm sorry yeah but that's what's on tick
tock no
not really unless you go down that
algorithm i'm not down an algorithm this
is just my regular instagram feed i
don't know if they haven't figured it
out yet why are you following 50 year
old women
no those are like my friends from
facebook that moved over to instagram
now because they figured out 15 years
later instagram's cooler than facebook
and now they're doing your own friends
on facebook i have many 50 year old
friends on facebook
and now they're doing all the tick tock
dances i'm like i don't think this
is right anyway so wait like i said i
think instagram is going to kill so
oracle
doesn't have a consumer facing social
media or video business
in theory oracle could use customer data
collected by tick tock to improve its
marketing products what do you think
about who wrote this
what do you think about that alex
sherman
actually alex is very uh good alex
i think that's a good theory i think
that's i don't think that's a great
theory at all
here's why i don't think it's a great
theory is because uh
i actually don't think that oracle's
gonna use the date this isn't a data
play for oracle
well why not how do you know they have
tick tock has so much data that could
benefit
because the value that they get out of
not using the data and letting tic toc
continue to operate and have people
trust it would be exponentially more
than like oh let's steal some data and
then use it to like but
they fix our market they can still let
it
go independently oracle is not
advertising to 18 year olds
facts all right what's up you just said
it's not only 18 year olds on tick tock
cnbc kate rooney reporting
why are you naming the reporters robin
hood
robin hood snags third mega investment
of the year boosting valuation to a love
oh did you like that hair flip right
there
all right so robin hood the fintech app
is that a stock
app stock millennial app brokerage
oh brokerage mobile enabled technology
innovation
okay okay raised 200 million
in funding which makes its valuation
11.2 billion which is up from 8.6
billion everybody knows robin hood
can i just say i had just started
fortune in 2014 and they were tiny teeny
and i really wanted to write about them
but anyway i didn't but
i knew this was going to be big and now
it's 11.2 and i was using it see
polina actually did meet the founders
early
was very convinced that this was going
to be big we won't say who the people
are but there was people who were trying
to convince her like oh all the startups
have all these grand plans
well they do they do but but this very
few of them
end up being worth 11 billion dollars
and it has nothing to do with the fact
that one of the founders is bulgarian
but maybe it does
so what's interesting here is uh they
just raised
money um series g funding
no that's this round but they just
raised whatever comes before g
uh like earlier this year at eight point
six percent
uh but yeah they had a july it was 320
million right no no
yeah oh in april in april they raised
money previously and an 8.6 or 8.6
billion dollar value
he loves walk by so much it's 8.6
percent
apy shout out to block for it what up
uh all right so here's the deal as you
guys can tell i'm a little tired today
but
um i think that what is really
interesting about robin hood
uh this is my personal belief this is
not uh
flynna's belief but maybe she'll jump in
i think that
just as square has crushed
robin hood in terms of i think square's
brokerage business is going to be bigger
than robin hoods
in the next five years it's because when
you start out building these companies
you can either start out with brokerage
or you start out with deposits and
payments
square start with deposits and payments
robin hood started out with uh brokerage
so the only way that robin hood can
really grow is they can either add new
products or they can expand in new
geographies
the same way square can how come i
haven't heard of square's brokerage
business
hold on a second but what you end up
seeing
is that robin hood has tried to expand
geographically ran into some issues and
kind of contracted a little bit so
they're staying and focusing on the us
market
so in order to grow really what they're
going to do is add more services so if
you remember they tried to add a cash
balance
uh service previously didn't go so hot
because the regulators got upset
they added crypto not a big part of
their business it's very hard for them
to go and add
other types of services so are they
going to add credit cards debit cards
are they gonna be able to get into
financial products like
all of those things payments right it's
very hard for a brokerage business to
transition to a financial services
company
in reverse though somebody like square
that started with deposits and payments
they now have payments they have kiosks
they have point of sale software
they've got crypto right bitcoin was a a
huge part of the cash app uh revenue and
profit
in the last quarter they have uh
fractional shares or brokerage like
they can add tons of things because they
start with they own your deposits
i think that's a key difference here um
and so you don't
know of squares fractional shares
or their brokerage business but they
have
30 million users that are actively using
it every single month
it ain't me i don't know if it's a
fractional shares but it's like 30
million people who are transacting on
the cash app
uh platform and so what ends up
happening is like it's gonna be very
easy to show those people the product
and get them to start using
icic yeah i by the way robin has a great
business i'm long robin hood
hot take let's do that i also think that
what robin hood is doing
uh in terms of allowing people to front
run all the uh
the retail traders is a little suspect
because most users probably don't know
what's happening
um but that's neither here nor there
we'll talk about that later by the way
our friend howard lindsey i love things
neither here nor there
yes our friend howard lindsen was uh i
don't know angel investor or seed
investor
in the robin hood uh howie i know you're
going to let everyone know that now it's
worth 11 billion dollars
oh he will but congratulations god what
if i had invested
hopefully he didn't uh he actually you
know what he told me
fund one has uh the seat run well he
didn't tell me i saw it on twitter
uh fund one for his firm has
uh robin hood seed round fund two has
their series a
so good job well good job all right
what's next well it's nice for him
okay so um he's definitely gonna get
paid i think
so i think given all the news with
fintech i think there's kind of been a
fintech
boom shall i say amex
is acquiring softbank-backed cabbage
k cabbage yes it's atlanta based
i believe um so basically cabbage had
built a platform that uses machine
learning algorithms to assess and loan
out money to small
business owners and uh the
terms of the deal not disclosed but
reports earlier this month put the value
of the acquisition at up to 850 million
and for some context cabbage had raised
nearly 990
billion that's a typo 990 million in
debt and equity
and at least 3.5 billion in
securitizations that that can't be right
right
990 billion uh i'm not sure
no nobody's raising 990 billion dollars
uh well 900
not 90 billion 990 billion in equity and
debt i don't think they'll be able to
give out that much debt um
and look this is a down round so it was
last value to 1.2 billion
buy softbank if it only sold for 850
million dollars
that's about a 25 haircut give or take
and so this is what happens right so
cabbage though
no it's just softbank probably overpaid
for it oh no of course but
so amex kind of wants it to build out a
small business arm or look what's going
on all these
legacy financial services companies they
don't have the technical chops in-house
you have to remember okay i want to be
technically uh advanced
all right cool how do i do that well i
have to go get people who can build this
new technology and think like an
entrepreneur
and be innovative uh and build these
services okay cool where do we go find
those people
oh wait none of those people want to
work here right so that's one of the
hard parts for these large financial
services firms is the recruiting
and retention of these types of
employees yeah so one of the best things
you can do is just go
buy the company that's already collected
a bunch of that talent has a product in
market has figured out a lot of this
stuff
and then you can bolt it onto your
business right and the promise to the
founders is like hey we're american
express we can just like
put you in front of a bunch of people
drive your customer acquisition costs
down like there's quote-unquote
synergies whatever the hell that means
didn't visa recently by somebody like
that i don't remember
god damn it okay how do you say this
diageo sure oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah well bye ryan reynolds is
aviation gin all right for 610
million i got a question aviation
american gin
it says that it's co-owned by
ryan reynolds but did he start this or
is he just like a minority in
this uh i thought he started it but
are you sure i really thought so diagio
already paid up uh a billion dollars i
think it was for casa amigos it says he
would
it says he would retain his uh
his interest required oh okay here we go
so reynolds wait go back
ryan reynolds acquired an unspecified
minority stake in aviation gin in 2018
since when the brand had thrived
oh since when the brand has thrived
diageo the world's largest spirit maker
we have found two typos today well so
here's the crazy part
is everyone's talking about ryan
reynolds
gin company it sounds like ryan reynolds
made an investment
but he blew it up so much it sounded
like it was his own yeah and part of the
investment was basically to do this so
look great for them uh i just don't
think that he's getting 610 million
dollars
wait yes oh my god yes okay do you guys
remember
that peloton ad with that woman who was
like
like her husband got her the peloton for
christmas or something
and everyone was like oh my god that's
so sexist and then
he got her to be in a commercial for
aviation
yeah he got the actress to be in a
commercial for aviation gin
and where she was just like i need a
drink basically after this
crazy they were making fun they were
making fun of a woman and they went and
then they basically capitalized on it
yeah but not really no no in a smart way
it was very smart
and she got paid twice it was
tongue-in-cheek yeah it was awesome
so look there is consolidation happening
in the
uh spirits industry um i think that uh
we're gonna see more and more of this
but uh can i
pray for these guys can i ask why all
these celebrities want like gin
and tequila and vodka remember when uh
p diddy sean diddy combs sold sarak
oh yeah back in like two thousand and
you think that's why
no no i'm just saying like they were
like yo say what you want
puff daddy p diddy diddy shawn combs
whatever you want to call him he was
ahead of the curve
you know what you should do what you
should start a a
you should promote a brand of rakia
nah i'm not messing with the rakia
anybody from eastern europe knows
me and rakia we cool man yeah but like i
respect the rakia the rakia specs
respects me nobody has done that yeah
so for anyone who doesn't yeah eastern
europe there is uh i thought you're
gonna stop
uh there's this alcohol called rakia
uh and it basically just puts you on
it's called different things in
different places but in bulgaria it's
called okay
all right what's up last one bang bang
all right
there's a new shortage because of the
pandemic
it's not toilet paper it ain't paper
towels do you know what it is
what pepperoni
yeah i know i love pepperoni small pizza
shops across the nation are reporting
higher prices for pepperoni
which found a south dakota shop paying
four
dollars and 12 cents a pound compared to
287 in january of 2019.
so basically there's a pepperoni
shortage and
a large pizza chains including domino's
pizza hut little caesars and papa john's
have experienced shortages or price
increases as they buy new
buy ingredients with long-term contracts
if the pepperoni prices are going up
that means the unit economics of pizzas
are getting thrown off which means that
now all of a sudden the small businesses
that are probably getting crushed also
now have
worsening economic unit economics which
could put them under more
financial pressure which means that the
government could have to print more
money in order to give them
pizza money ppp which then would put a
strain and increase the likelihood of
inflation so basically the pepperoni
pizza is stealing the wealth of the
bottom 50
of americans
does this mean we're gonna have to pay
more for our pizza uh
dominoes i doubt in the short term
they'll change pricing but if this
persists my guess is for more than 30
days then people would start looking to
change pricing and also it depends on
small businesses versus
uh chains yeah i mean i hear you
do you have funny jokes as a bookmark
oh my god all right come on hit me with
a joke and then let's get out of here
all right all right
what do you call a farm that makes bad
jokes what do i make what i call a farm
that makes bad jokes oh plainest place
close what corny
that joke was corny you're corny
he's corny tell him i'm not gonna say
anything that was a that was bait right
there you see how she tried to be people
in the comments are asking for
you to start telling jokes and you got
no jokes
knock knock sup
orange aren't you annoying orange you
annoying
orange orangey special orange
what aren't you going to leave me alone
now
no all right guys that's it for lunch
monday today well while she's trying to
get rich with us
trying to get our lunch money tune in
tomorrow for episode number
100. tomorrow's episode 100 i might go
crazy for that one
all right see you guys bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends